aime cette ville la ville aux
opportunités infinies prête à faire éclater ta cerise
viens sur une ville comme n'importe quelle autre juste plus grande
je viens de frapper une autre ville les légendes sont nées
ici dans la nature des semaines roulant ton cos
Dex tirant les ficelles le doute qui met
fin et nous les perdons mais  nous
ne le savons tout simplement pas encore, mais si vous avez
les cojones et que vous savez comment les utiliser,
vous pouvez faire n'importe quoi à moins que
vous n'attrapiez la balle, même si vous sortez
avec un bang, vous savez que vous pouvez faire des
tas plus  un conférencier motivateur yo mr.
V un plaisir alors quel est le jeu Dex que nous
voulions sortir en un seul morceau
[Musique]
que diriez-vous de revoir le plan il y a
ce prototype à biopuce pour être des
travaux précis l'usine
Desna appartient à une héritière de la cour après
avoir volé des poids lourds  chantage-
moi connard
comment est-ce qu'il y a une première guerre film complet après la
ligne pour couper le roi bébé
il va sans dire que nous faisons cela dans le
silence je traite avec personne personne ne semble
assez simple
[Musique]
est-ce que ça va être dangereux ne t'inquiète pas
nous avons plus de hack nous sommes à l'épreuve des balles ce qui
vient de se passer là-dedans il a
arrêté de creuser bien me voir [ __ ] heureux
maintenant Jackie oh mon dieu était tellement foutu